Replacement,
replacement is also at work in languages.
Do you know that at the end of this avenue,
there is 1 pharmacy called pharmacy de Paris
or pharmacy is written saïdaliath
in Arabic,
That's right,
that kind of little detail.
For me,
these are symptoms of civil war
that only ask
manifest themselves more violently.
1 civil war,
it does not fit
in no way the situation we are in.
1 civil war,
it's something
that takes place within a people.
The current situation is not at all
1 opposition within a people.
The situation we are in,
it is 1 and that could happen.
I hope that won't be the case,
although I wish for its result,
but its outcome perhaps.
Without war,
it is a colonial war of liberation.
We are in 1 stadium,
in 1 phase of colonization,
and if
something is going to happen,
it's a colonial war,
1 war of liberation,
whether it is colonial or not,
that it is as well 1 war,
uh,
of liberation like Europe.
We knew a lot in the 19th century at the time of,
of, of
nationality,
but it has nothing to do with a civil war,
whatever the number,
it is true extremely abundant,
employees.
So that would be one aspect of civil war,
because the la,
the colonial power certainly has many allies,
the replacements
are obviously called by the replacements.
But finally,
it is not at all 1 Civil war situation,
it's really a war situation between
very different peoples.
Except that as long as these people have papers,
say in French,
they are French,
and therefore we can speak of civil war.
Even if I agree with you on the quality
not French essentially from these people,
this is their papers,
on the order of pure illusion,
to the extent that
where they call the French the French,
or theyly say the French,
the other French.
I agree with you,
the man has established himself that they are not French,
but since they won't leave,
for me it is already 1 situation of civil war.
Oh, some,
the elements,
uh.
Who are of the order of politics
and not at all from the war,
could destroy them,
or get 1 number of them to leave,
since so many things brought them here.
I may delete
which brought them in for,
uh,
to name a few.
I agree with you.